[Musique]
merci d'avoir invité un dinosaure
on est généreux silicon valley avant qui
s'appelle se recueillera les pourparlers
de l'information c'est un sujet qui vous
concerne tous
c'est au coeur de la société actuelle et
comme indiqué je vois pas parler des
technologies de l'information mais
plutôt de ces questions fondamentales
est-ce que l'information est la
propriété privée ou plutôt un bien en
commun je suis biologiste de formation
j'ai étudié dans mes recherches
les récifs coralliens pour le seuil de
comprendre comment est ce que les
milliers d'espèces de toutes sortes pour
se mettre ensemble pour construire c'est
une merveille de la nature qui sont les
récifs corrézien et étudions comment
fonctionnait cette épouse système j'ai
pu comprendre d'autres d'air leur façon
de communiquer entre eux les liaisons
active et passive d'information qui ont
pas mis tous ces organismes se mettre
ensemble et devenir productif et
efficace et bâtir cinq structures qui
sont comblés les grandes villes
d'aujourd'hui donc cette approche
systémique
c'est au fond de mes la poche maintenant
maintenant je vais avec la question de
gouvernance internationale à toutes les
échelles pour essayer d'appliquer ces
questions ces principes
d'abord un peu d'histoire il y à 200 300
euros en angleterre les aristocrates ont
décidé qu'ils veulent s enrichir en
mettant des clôtures autour des
pâturages pour garder surtout de
l'argent déposé dans les prisons d'accès
à la ressource
c'était la présentation des communaux
aujourd'hui nous vivons une nouvelle
plantation des communaux les communaux
de l'information mais ce n'est plus les
aristocrates c'est les grandes
multinationales qui ont bâti leur
fortune de la technologie d'information
qu'ils sont en train de nous exploiter
d'aspirer tous nos données du monde même
dépendant de le système
j'ai lu il ya deux jours en angleterre
les personnes moyenne passe trois heures
par jour sur les réseaux sociaux
et on sait si vous cliquez sur une like
sur facebook
si vous envoyer un tweet ça touche le
même sont de plaisir dans le cerveau que
la cocaïne et il sait bien connue de 16
ans d'ordination common coûts diverses
et dépendances pour nous on emprunte
partie de cette collecte de données qui
nous permettent de faire le big dada
attaque lesquels des cibles des
publicités mises à nu sublime pour
devenir des consommateurs dépendantes
principe des produits et donc on a
manipulé
quand tous ses processus et ses les
questions éthiques
où est l'intérêt commun dans sept
systèmes techniques pratiquées
actuellement ça pose des questions
éthiques à différents niveaux
d'abord est-ce qu'ils existent en droit
d'accès à l'information
ou peut-être est-ce qu'on peut
distinguer entre l'information auquel on
a droit et d'autres termes à sion peut
être plutôt les divertissements pour
lequel est logique qu'on devait payer
mais pour ceux qui son propos pour
accéder à l'information est si le
président table pour la société qui
n'ont pas accès vous savez aujourd'hui
qu'on a dans le monde
les inégalités entre les riches et les
pauvres devient de plus en plus
importante
la moitié des populations l'humanité est
très pauvre et quelques personnes
souvent avec les fortunes bâties ou sur
l'information
cette information sont devenus
énormément riche il se déshabille
société il ya les mêmes inégalités pour
l'information entre ceux qui n'ont pas
accès à l'information et ceux qui ont
peut-être trop on se sont noyés
l'information aujourd'hui avec ces
nouveaux technologies deuxième question
pour la création de l'information pour
la cré vite et la médiathèque
est ce que le seule motivation c'est le
profit
nous tournons rythme actuel c'était
mettant le monde
sapri veille pour que les gens profitent
et sinon ils vont pas inventé mais n'y
at il pas d'autres motivations
la curiosité scientifique ou peut être
nous l'avons service aux autres avancées
la civilisation où est l'intérêt général
donc tout ça et comment quotidien
intérêt général pour l'individu s'était
plutôt roulant de questions éthiques
c'est quelqu'un veut simplement être
riche et puissante et vend ses
développeurs et le maximum de richesses
pour poursuivre sa lutte
si par contre on veut avoir une vie qui
en 7 1 107 1 valeur environ en service
aux autres ont su motiver à travailler
autrement
mais pour les entreprises aujourd'hui de
ses motivations et le profit est ce
normal que tout se fait pour augmenter
leurs profits et son procès reste pour
dépoter pas les données aussi à
motivations sociales responsable social
pour qu'aussi il sonne besoin de servir
la société
quelques exemples nous avons un système
de propriété intellectuelle qui est
organisée par l'ong mondial de produits
intellectuels de l'onu à genève
c'est eux qui s'occupent système des
brevets et des marques déposées et des
droits d'auteur etc
ils ont toujours un débat est ce normal
qu'on rende tout ça privé où ils n'ont
jamais pu me reprendre cette question
j'essaie de trouver un certain équilibre
mais si on voit par exemple les cas où
il ya un médicament breveté et il le
comprenait qui le fabrique le vend très
cher parce qu'il célébrait veille c'est
le profit des actionnaires
les claques entier trop pauvres pour
payer les médicaments
il va mourir parce qu'il peut pas est ce
normal que les gens meurent pour
défendre les dividendes des actionnaires
il ya quelque chose d' éthique de ces
deux ans qu'on n'a pas vraiment réglé un
autre exemple l'agriculture
vous savez depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale on est aux deux systèmes en
parallèle d'une recherche agricole
d'un côté les descentes recherche
agricole données cgiar qui ont créé des
bas dès bons
pensent ils ont protégé librement entre
les points de soins de recherche pour
trouver les croisements les mieux
adaptés à chaque situation
c'étaient eux qui derrière les relations
ouvertes qui ont permis à l'inde de
passer d'une paye de famine à un pays
exportateur de la nourriture c'était une
grande avancée à côté on avait six
multinationales agricoles qui ont blair
était récemment ce qui pourrait mettre
ensemble a déclaré abhisit dans les
produits chimiques pour vendre le paquet
pour la culture industrielle à grande
échelle unis feront tout le monde entier
parce que c'est mieux pour le profit est
ce qu'on veut un monopole de monoculture
universités écologique qui est
traitement plus durable c'est un joueur
qui n'est pas encore vraiment fait en
plus l'agriculture va peut-être devenir
le domaine la prochaine privatisation de
l'information maintenant avec des traits
la direction avec les drones on peut se
souvenir tous les champs snm société va
proposer ses services pour aider la veut
dire savoir est-ce qu'il faut arroser
plus ici est-ce qu'il fallait mettre
pesticides là bas parce que quelque
chose arrive et c'est pour les aider à
obtenir un bon en même temps tous ces
données sont collectées par ces sociétés
privées qui peut avoir le vue d'ensemble
de la culture et qui peut changer le
système premier profite pas pour le bien
de tout le monde
est-ce qu'on veut que toute animation
dépendre cremonini nationale qui sont là
que pour en profiter mais le nageur
yannick et dans plus de plus pour
protéger par les brevets il y avait par
exemple les gènes les mutations qui ont
favorisé le cancer du sein dans les
femmes qui étaient béteille s'ils
voulaient savoir qui est susceptible et
par le passé par là pour faire les
analyses
il y avait une femme pour lesquels les
données de départ que l'éclair donc il
savait pas évoluer avant deuxième avis
ils ont refusé d'honorer ses propres
analyses
parce que c'était un secret industriel
il y avait tout un procès pour que
finalement établir que peut-être des
pains bonne idée de breveter les jeunes
mais même la formation scientifique et
couvertes par le droit d'auteur est de
plus en plus régionaux scientifiques
sont devenus son a été acheté pour les
grandes
c'était d'édition scientifique qui gère
aussi ces informations pour leur propre
profit
je n'ai même pas pu consulter mes
propres publications
parce que je suis à la retraite j'ai pas
besoin d'investir à côté qui perd les
abonnements donc ils me demandent 3 30
dollars 50 pour lire mes propre site de
recherche scientifique
est ce logique ou même sers de mon grand
père publié il ya 100 ans ou là aussi le
jour nanterre à acheter ils sont
disponibles en ligne payant et pour les
scientifiques du tiers-monde comme che
guevera ici dans ce petit village en
inde
comment rester à la pointe de recherche
si tout est payant si le plus accès à
ces données scientifiques
aujourd'hui l'information n'est pas
quelque chose de matériel comme une
pomme je mange une pomme pourrie par de
manger mais si je ne mange comme ça
peut-être générale hier marque déposée
auquel j'ai emprunté j2ee pas copier
cette façon de manger les pommes
parce que il est maintenant déposer mais
l'information
bon si on achète une libye la logique
vous payez l'imprimerie le papier etc
mais c'est peut-être des matières et les
mêmes informations peut passer sur
l'internet par les ondes radios télés et
7 protège et est très facile et ça coûte
rien de le protéger comme ça en plus
le portail d'information augmente la
richesse c'est 1000 personnes lire
papiers scientifiques qui sont tous en
russie si un million c'est la fédération
ne perdent pas en valeur n'est pas
consommée au contraire il est enrichi de
plus qu'il est protégé ça c'est l'outil
de zad et et cette programmation c'est
utile pour tout soit touchée où ça ça
permette la transparence politique
le despote depuis missionnaire arrêter
les journalistes et contre les armes à
sion pour se protéger ça permettra plus
tard à 100 on peut pratiquer dans les
démocraties ont peu contribué à
l'organisation des nations-unies pour
les idées pour les documents se
partagent aussi c'est important pour
construire la société va de prochaines
hausses notre santé et notre
environnement
on est informé des dangers autour de
nous pour l'information l'accès à la
a sion donc la libre circulation de
l'information est essentiel pour le
fonctionnement de notre société soutient
dans l'intérêt de tous
avec l'internet on a des technologies
pour le faire encore plus facilement que
par le passé donc il est logique on peut
devant la presse cette capacité pour le
partage il y a même des conventions pour
l'accès à l'information comme le
pensionnat russe en europe pour garantir
l'accès et cette même transparence nous
protègent contre les dangers de
manipulation quand j'étais à leur nous
un moment ont posé deux questions
pourquoi ils 21 14 soit au rwanda et on
te rendre compte après que c'était parce
qu'il y avait des stations radio mille
collines qu'ont fait les émissions pour
inciter à la haine en tribunes contre
love hewitt cent mille personnes ont été
massacrées procès de mauvais partage de
l'information
donc il faut exposer ses problèmes en
amont voir maintenant les pays qui s'est
ingéré dans les actions de votre pays
vous jouez dans des actions il faut
créer les divisions établir les pays
dont et par la transparence pour éviter
tous ces manipulations ces dangers de
manipulation donc comment bénéficier de
la créativité
ce n'est pas en la privatisant on a
souvent des petits bancs publics pour la
recherche
le gourmand c'est normal de financer les
recherches fondamentales on absolument
des postes de chercheurs ont introduit
de recherche ou dans une université où
on est payé pour créer mais on n'a pas
payé par berlin et/ou par bonne idée en
papier c'est un salaire pour être
créateurs ont pu imaginer les primes
d'innovation le crowdsourcing ça marche
pour certains tics nerveux nation peut
même penser à changer le système pour
qu'il y ait un partage des revenus
tout le monde pour accélaration mais si
on en profite et à les protéger les
profits avec ce qu'il avait créée donc
il y a des choses à faire
par exemple les actualités c'est
essentiel pour rester informé de la
société de travailler dans un bar
brasserie formation est ce logique que
l'information soit financée par la
publicité pour nous bombarder avec des
massages tant qu'on n'a pas envie pour
des choses qu'on doit pas acheter et
cetera pour financer le travail c'est
important pour la société
le guardian avait décidé de faire
autrement
ils ont mis en ligne tous les antiques
petit un entrepôt si vous avez apprécié
l'antique et mais nous aider à vous
informer si vous contribuez maintenant
il reçoit plus d'argent pour les
contributions volontaires qu'ils ont
reçu avant pour la publicité
donc ça peut marcher donc pour revenir à
4 centimes systémique
le système les plus évolués les plus
complexes les plus productives sont ceux
qui ont des réseaux de communication et
de coordination les plus diverses et les
plus riches donc c'est l'information qui
n'est accessible à ces sociétés de
fonctionnaires site corallien une
société actuelle donc limiter la
circulation de l'information ralenti
l'avancement de nos sociétés j'ouvre les
yeux sur votre génération d'innover pour
trouver des solutions à toutes les
questions
je vous ai posé cette comédie merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]